hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
[Applause]
monday hi monday
december 21st 2020 what's going on how
are you
oh jimmy crack corn that's not a
christmas song i want you to sing a
christmas song here we go i'm
i'm throwing my left fist out here
trying to think of one
a good one oh i'm the king of the twin
king of the swingers now the jungle vip
all guys kid songs in my head
i've reached the top and had to stop and
that's what's bothering me
i want to be a man man cub and stroll
right into town it'd be just like the
other men
i'm tired of my what we do i won i'm
sorry
merry christmas everybody that's what
i'm trying to say happy hanukkah
post hanukkah to all the jewish people
listening there uh
happy kwanzaa and
uh what do they do in the muslim world
this time of year you got to have a guy
everybody's got a guy
everybody's got a guy what do you guys
light up and put on your front yards
there
muslim i almost wrote muslim christmas
and i would have got put on a hit list
oh it comes up [ __ ] let's see what we
got here the five pillars of islam
okay fine resources of teaching islamic
holidays bam see what they got in
december
uh the key dates
april may july august august
oh it's august all right well then happy
uh post-tenth
maharam there we go i covered everybody
i think
okay there we go um all right how are
you guys doing there
i know this podcast is a little bit late
um
you know had some family things i had to
deal with
uh before i got into this whole thing
let's talk uh let's talk football right
out of the gallon wait let's talk about
all the shopping i have left to do i
thought i was done and then uh
you know i got a couple nieces and
nephews that are a little bit older i
didn't know what was going to be going
on with them and all of a sudden you
know their families are sending my kids
gifts and i'm like oh [ __ ]
oh snap caught with my pants down here
so i got to go run out to gatasana
um to go buy some [ __ ] giving the gift
of music fortunately my nieces and
nephews there's a lot of uh
people that play you know couple guitar
players some drummers
piano players and all of that type of
stuff that's really cool um
i mean i guess with the younger kids i
should probably get him a yeah
a yap a laptop right
get him a [ __ ] laptop with some uh
you know owl head
or something you put that on
you know
[Music]
oh [ __ ] right right as the molly kicks
it
that really is the perfect
music i feel like for this generation if
you see what's going on in the world i
mean that's a good soundtrack
that's what everybody sounds like when
they're talking
you know i feel like we're reaching the
end of days oh come on bill it's the
holidays all right
all right well it's [ __ ] 80 degrees
out here that's even hot for out here
are we gonna have to change the story of
santa as global warming gets crazier and
crazier what's it gonna be
what does rudolph become no more
reindeer right they probably got to
switch to
uh [ __ ] the rate we're going to be some
sort of reptile uh i can't have a
reptile they're not cute
they're just not cute oh speaking of
which
speaking a witch um
speaking of jewish people
let me make sure i got this right
jerusalem
bug jerusalem cricket
i had one of these in my [ __ ] garage
holy [ __ ] you got to see this thing it
hasn't
what's weird is it has nothing to do
with the middle east israel or anything
but it's called the jeru jerusalem
cricket
this [ __ ] thing died in my
my garage i came in and it looked like
like an ant in a hornet had a kid
and that kid did peds you know and made
it to the show
and then got busted and then its whole
life [ __ ] unraveled and then it just
died in my garage i think that was the
for 30 on this this bug
um i was afraid to touch it because i
couldn't tell if it was alive or not
and it had a pretty uh i don't had those
stripes on the back like it could sting
you and had some
fangs and [ __ ] um
but i'm not gonna lie to you man that
thing is the thing is a meal
like if i was a political prisoner or
something and they were starving me a
protein
and a jerusalem cricket came in i think
i'd be less afraid
that's got to be hard man you know when
you're eating bugs
you can't totally smash the thing
because then you got to lick it off the
wall
then i kind of feel like it's like a
beating a bug is like eating an
artichoke
you know it's not all edible you gotta
kind of get this stuff i'm sorry what am
i doing with this
that's what i feel like it is right
um anyway plowing ahead here
uh you know i finally listened to a
little bit of that tom cruise rant
and i just i don't understand the [ __ ]
that the guy's getting for it okay
it's like you know what the deal is
you're on a movie set
be a [ __ ] professional and you could
tell by the way he was yelling that was
probably the 9
000th [ __ ] time he had to tell some
dumb
[ __ ] to stop being a dumb [ __ ]
all right you know on any movie if you
shut it down for a day or two
like the movie is immediately in trouble
forget about when you're doing a movie
at his level
where the [ __ ] budget is like you
know nine figures
and yet dumbass wants to go play [ __ ]
grab ass with somebody else yeah tom
cruise is gonna snap
it's called being a professional and
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
that are quitting the movie i was just
joking with my friends going like how
did we went from bobby knight to this
now bobby bobby would get a little
sideways i'm not saying i approved of
everything that the guy did but you know
this whole [ __ ] thing he yelled at me
it was upsetting it's just like you're
on a movie set people are gonna get
yelled at
somebody's gonna [ __ ] snap it's not
normal
to be working 16-hour [ __ ] days
every single day five six days a week
for months on end people are going
to snap okay since i've been in this
business
i've heard that's all you hear about is
people [ __ ] sn
i've had people snap on me get right in
my grill [ __ ]
screaming a bunch of [ __ ] at me and then
the next day they come yeah
sorry about that it's like dude i get it
i get it
[Music]
we all want to be here we all want to do
this but this on certain days it sucks
and you start losing your [ __ ] mind
um totally normal behavior but uh
but as always they go after the
quarterback like they're doing with the
los angeles rams right now
for some reason they're blaming that
whole loss
on jared goff at least they were on uh
uh
good morning football i was watching
that this morning i like that show
and god damn they would destroy it first
of all they didn't they barely gave the
jets props
for winning the game by the way as a
pats fan congratulations jets fans
j-e-t-j-e-t-s jet jets jets
i'm too stupid to spell it um
yeah i don't want to see anybody go owen
16. i was rooting
for the browns that year for the lions
that year to get a win
nobody wants to see that if you want to
see that you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what you are you know what you
are you're the 72 dolphins
that's who the [ __ ] you are every year
rooting for teams
to fail i think that's why the dolphins
have never won again because of those
smug [ __ ] every year
toasting a glass yeah nobody did no one
else should ever do it again but
us
you know what that's like that's like a
dad rooting against his son
because he's not secure enough to
[ __ ] handle
i don't understand that at all and every
year they have to go to those [ __ ]
guys
you know maybe it's not their fault
maybe it's them because the media is
talking about it or whatever but like i
i love that team i love all of those
guys zonka kick
bob greasy paul warfield mercury morris
don shula rest his soul
uh who was on defense on that one
oh nick monaconi rest his soul i like
all of those [ __ ] guys because jake
scott on that team
i like all of those guys all right but
like i i'm this this whole [ __ ] thing
where
you know like that is is that the
history of the dolphins
so they're never gonna win again and all
they're gonna do is celebrate that
nobody
even though somebody wins a super bowl
every [ __ ] year because they have one
or two losses
the 72 dolphins are still the greatest
team of all time like that's what you're
going to hang your hat on you've been
doing it for almost 50 [ __ ] years
i would have to think as a giant as a
dolphin fan you'd like to move beyond
that
you know i mean dolphin fans they're
like nick fans
knicks won it in 70 and 73 they've never
shut up about those [ __ ] teams
because they got nothing else
and i'm not being a dick here i have uh
two of my
best friends in the world are [ __ ]
the most hardcore knick fans ever and
every year i would come the draft i'm
i'm
rooting that they're gonna pick the
right guy i was hoping durant
was gonna go to uh
to the knicks i'm not being a dick here
and by the way jesus christ he
he went to the the brooklyn nets and uh
i caught a little bit of the game they
were putting a [ __ ] ass kicking on my
celtics
they were up by like almost 30 points at
the half or something 25
30 points um immediately missed tommy
hindson
rest his soul man really really going to
miss that guy in the broadcast booth
um just listening to him getting on the
refs and everything
sucks but it is it is what life is
people die
you got to move on this isn't even for
you guys this is for me
um all right what else can you believe
basketball's already
back oh that's right it's not a man's
game anymore
i'm sorry i think i already did that
joke on this podcast it's one of my
favorite things
he's gonna dunk everybody clear out so
you don't end up on
instagram you used to have to be a man
to dunk in this [ __ ] league
going into the trees this is what they
used to say
um so anyway congratulations to the new
york jets
i was actually watching a great game uh
kansas city chiefs versus the uh new
orleans saints
and for some reason the game started
later like 1 30 out here so
me and my buddy clicked over and we
started watching
the rams and jets you know we were kind
of watching on the ticker and i was like
come on man i want to see the jets win
one i don't want to see him go
winless so when we clicked over like we
never went back to the other game we
just sat there watching it
uh the great frank gore making some
veteran plays uh it was a big win
and then for some reason they all came
down on good morning football today i
didn't get it
i get you know trashing the rams for
losing
and they needed it you know to stay in
the playoff picture or whatever but like
you know to put it all on the
quarterback i mean i i don't get that
you you win and lose as a [ __ ] team
and then they're getting on him like
he's making all this [ __ ] money and i
i looked the guy up he's like 11th in
the league
almost top ten gonna throw for 4 000
[ __ ] yards
you know he's got 20 touchdowns 12
interceptions all right you'd like to
see maybe a bigger spread there but i
mean
who's he throwing to he seems to be
doing
if i had to look at those stats and then
at their record maybe they could should
score some more points in the red zone i
have no idea but i wouldn't put the
whole [ __ ] thing on him
and i would also give the jets to
goddamn do they want a game
good for them um i also watched a little
bit of the packers this week
and uh my apologies to aaron rodgers i'm
sitting there talking about russell
wilson good thing you know i think he's
the best guy in the league
i just wasn't paying attention to the
packers for whatever reason
first of all there's like [ __ ] 50
teams now 20 divisions
and i got two kids under the age of four
so i'm i'm a little off here
i mean i was always off but um i had no
excuse before i was just dumb
aaron rodgers before the game last uh
yesterday or whatever whenever they
played
i can't remember if it was thursday or
saturday saturday they played
guy he's got 40 touchdowns and four
interceptions
that's a nice spread um
and this year i am not rooting against
anybody
because my team is officially out of it
and i'm just going to enjoy all of this
[ __ ] buffalo bills
kicking ass again again i think they're
peaking at just
are they peaking a little bit so early
you gotta ask yourself that
um they put up 40-something on somebody
i don't know who the hell it was but uh
my patriots kind of had our typical day
you know
we do got your corey myers that's that's
a bright spot for next year
but um i think belichick did a great job
this year with what we've had
we had some brutal injuries we had a
bunch of guys
you know opt out because of covid so
i don't think we are nearly as bad as as
the rest of the league thinks which i
like
but we definitely need uh a big draft or
some sort of a trade here if we're going
to keep up with the bills because
um it's looking like their division
for the foreseeable future the way
they're playing which is great because
those goddamn bill fans have
they haven't won anything since like 63
or 64.
didn't the bills win an afl title i used
to know that
um as i looked this up i watched a great
game uh
i started to watch ohio state versus
northwestern but it was like watching
fifth graders play first graders
i hate those college matchups where you
i always look at the offensive and
defensive line to decide if i'm going to
watch a game
and like they were like four inches
taller and had 40 pounds on every guy in
the line and it's like all right
so this game right around the third
quarter they're gonna start impo
imposing their will and the game's going
to be over
but ohio state makes the playoffs which
would have
bugged me back in the day meaning last
year up until last year
especially with all the wine and ass
buckeye fans every year we should be
in it every year even if we don't win
the big ten championships
every [ __ ] year the biggest cry
babies
fans in [ __ ] football and you guys
earned that by the way
um i i now realize it's a business
the fact that they only played six games
they played six [ __ ] games and got in
the playoffs
and i'm sitting there going how in the
[ __ ] can you justify that when they're
going up against teams that play 10 11
12 [ __ ] games
like the advantage that they have is
ridiculous
you played six games so you're up and
running you're going and then you don't
have the wear and tear
five less games wear and tear so i think
they got a great chance
it went in the whole thing we shall see
um is there anything more uncomfortable
than watching alabama make a bad play
holy [ __ ] nick saban my god
yelling at that defensive coordinator
i mean i love seeing it i love an old
school coach that is not afraid to dress
down somebody in front of everybody
um jesus christ
[ __ ] that's why they're so great
i mean he literally wants to win by 50
and not give up a point
and he would just sit there and look at
you and be like yeah
what the [ __ ] are we doing out here this
is what this is what we're doing so
i believe the college playoff is uh what
is it it's alabama clemson ohio state
and i forget who the last one is
uh but i get it now it's a business you
got to have something
evidently they have to have somebody
from the big ten
no matter what even if they played half
a [ __ ] season they're still going to
stick them in there
because they got to get all those fat
midwestern people to turn tune into the
game
because for some weird reason you hate
everybody in your conference and then
in bowl games so you re you root for
your conference because you want to have
the strongest conference
i think that's that's like a leftover
from um
before they had like a playoff where you
know it was so much of it was strength
of schedule or whatever
um so you got to have that
and then you got to get all you got to
get them all there people down south you
got to get all them [ __ ] watching
right and then they don't give a [ __ ]
about the coasts because
it's uh you know we have pro teams and
[ __ ] and you know we live near oceans
and we think that we're we're better
than every other state we should just
fly over them because there's nothing to
do there that's what we think
generally speaking i don't speak for
everybody um
you got clamson got alabamu
right then you got the fat [ __ ] up in
ohio so everybody
all the way out to iowa's gonna watch
that [ __ ] and then who's the last guy
who is the last guy uh
college playoff
playoff
who's in it who's in who's in
let's see they got alabama crimson tide
11-0 played five more [ __ ] oh and
notre dame
notre dame oh man i used to love notre
dame i love notre dame until lou holtz
and i i just didn't buy it because they
were a big time college football program
and
just their whole [ __ ] that they
weren't doing anything wrong and then
lou holtz would always be yeah good day
you say your prayers
you say you do what you did you talk to
jesus
i just i couldn't found a guy i can't
deal with this guy
um so speaking of the j-e-t-s jets jets
jets you got to be watching the clemson
tigers in this playoff and be rooting
for your boy there at quarterback whose
name just escaped me
um because it's looking like he's going
to be a jet
which uh you know there you go
onward and upward see what happens um
all right what happened to this podcast
it all just [ __ ] slowed down right
there my brain just went blank here oh
mountain west championship
i ended up watching that san jose state
versus boise state
i got to see this kid avery williams
return yet another punt
or kickoff for a touchdown remember that
name
avery williams somebody is gonna pick
him he's mountain west so they'll
probably pick him up in the second
late second early third round and
uh he just set a record i guess most
in a season or in a college career
kickoff punt
punts for touchdowns uh it was a great
game
congratulations to san jose state
um i really enjoyed that i like mountain
west
i like that [ __ ] you know
you actually watch teams that both like
the same size playing each other it's
like a better game
instead of watching [ __ ] alabama
crimson tide you know
these [ __ ] kids show up they all look
like they're in their 30s
coming to games carrying briefcases and
[ __ ] um
all right that's it um what else what
else who's playing tonight
who's playing who's playing tonight
oh [ __ ] that let me tell you guys i got
a funny story for you i [ __ ] pull up
to a light and there's a homeless guy
allegedly homeless dude right
he's got gold earrings and a christmas
sweater on
i can't remember if he had a santa hat
or not but he was turning his back
as i was pulling up clearly counting
bills
he sticks him into his black slacks and
then turns around to me
and he goes he does like to have a heart
thing and i just look at this guy
and i'm usually nice to homeless people
i looked him right in the eye and just
shook my head no
and then he hung his head like a toddler
and i so bad wanted to roll my window
down but i'm worried about hepatitis i
wanted to roll my window down and be
like
are you begging in a in a s
christmas outfit
do you have like a walk-in closet
somewhere where you keep your gold
earrings
and your uh your holiday appropriate
begging wear
[Music]
i've never seen a homeless person dress
for the holidays
and just the way he was turned around
counting his money like a [ __ ] bookie
i was like
[ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this guy
i should have asked him for a light
because i was going over to go smoke a
[ __ ]
cigar um
i don't i don't usually i don't turn
away homeless people i usually do not
i have like a certain amount that i'll
give them because i want to make sure
they're eating but i also don't want to
give them enough money if they're an
addict to go [ __ ] od you know i play
that game but if you're going to show up
with gold earrings and a [ __ ]
you know one of those [ __ ] hipster
sweaters on and you put your hand on
your heart and when i say no you hang
your head like my toddler
it's just like dude you need to go home
and work on your act
you're clearly living inside somewhere
this is just [ __ ]
this is your [ __ ] hustle oh bill
you're a mean one
mr bird you've got ice
behind your freckles you're a [ __ ]
orange [ __ ] you should have given him a
bump
of cocaine
all right sorry about that by the way
thank you to everybody who's been
writing in
giving me all these suggestions for
french
films this person writes in
said i just saw a great french film
called only the animals
soos le bet i don't know how to say it
but uh
think fargo set in rural france yeah i'm
all over it
um let's see
okay the 10 french film listed below can
be found
on the criterion channel nice
uh film your next special in france on
35 millimeter
executing all of your material in french
it would be epic and throw your american
fans for a loop
hope your fam oh your family and you
have a merry christmas all right below
our third
are the films 13 days in france
as long as you've got your health
uh le circle rouge
the red circle is that what that is is
that too easy
diabolique je de fete
the red balloon a slightly pregnant man
vive le tour
yo yo all right badass french movie
you need to check out if you haven't
already is
lahaine a shot in black and white oh
yeah
yeah yeah i've seen that one i've seen
that one i saw the beginning of it
when i was on the road i got to watch
that that looks like train spotting
uh there's a scene that references a
famous
taxi driver scene okay another ones are
mesrin m-e-s-r-i-n-e killing zoe i've
seen that
the circular rouge the sicilian clan
okay that's the second time with
it's l e and then c-e-r-c-l-e rouge
r-o-u-g-e of course there is the
original
diabolique okay those are the first two
i'm watching
yes dude i'm getting this [ __ ] down
i'm listening to the plimsa app every
day
you know starting to get some phrases
down
let's see i'm going to have
breakfast with my daughter
at my house at my place would be uh
juve petite de janeiro
avec mafia
shemois right didn't that sound
impeccable french
look out eddie izzard um
kidding all right let's do some reads
here
eddie is it all right butcher box
my favorite my favorite line from eddie
izzard was
well do you have a flag
that was my favorite one talking about
england took over the world just with
like a flag
they would just show up and there was
already people there
well do you have a flag all right
butcher box everybody
box um talk about what you're looking
most forward to
in 2021 um getting the vaccine and
watching other people not get it
still get sick denied that this this
disease this virus exists
that's what i'm looking forward to uh
people telling me that i'm a globalist
[Laughter]
uh whoever the [ __ ] is fighting
globalism uh you're a little late
you're a little the damn has burst it
bursted
before you were even born it was it was
a [ __ ] rap
all right what are some of the new
year's resolutions you're making
um i got to get my instrument rating on
my helicopter
i got to do that i definitely with my
helicopter license i should say not my
helicopter my helicopter license i got
to get that rating
um
i mean i don't know i just the usual
stuff
working on my temper trying to be a
better dad and a husband
um i think that's it right
make sure i make my wife laugh every day
i used to do that all the time
effortlessly you know but now that we
got kids we're tired and everything i
kind of slipped
you know openly clown face i gotta i
gotta
i gotta i gotta make a comeback here
jacob the clown here
all right is that enough if i give
enough of my personal [ __ ]
self here so i can talk about the meat
get you murdered meat is murder
it's also delicious all right this year
i'm going to eat
better and spend less time and money at
the grocery store
thanks to butcher box
butcher box is the meat delivery
subscription that gives me
more time for what matters most each
month they send a box of the highest
quality meat for a better price than the
grocery store
which gives me more time to spend
cooking and sharing delicious meals with
the family and friends with the family
back east
luckily today's sponsor butcher box
believes everyone deserves high quality
humanely sourced meat
every month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
my home
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones
each box has a 9 to 11 pounds of meat
ladies enough for 24 individual meals
uh packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way
i can customize my box or go with one of
theirs either way
i get exactly what i watch butcher box
is a no-brainer it's the best meat
shipped right to my dealer
which means one last trip to the grocers
option yeah
grocery store is fur is for divorcees
okay
milling around [ __ ] the eggplant or
something trying to meet someone
options like 100 grass-fed and
grass-finished finished beef
free-range organic chicken my favorite
heritage pork
and wild-caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what they're gonna do
and sugar-free a sugar nitrate-free
bacon
it's the best meat way meat should be
it's the way meat should be sorry
butcher bucks is the most affordable and
convenient way to get healthy humane
humanely raised meat we already said
this
with butcher box you get the highest
quality meat for around just six dollars
a meal they did the math
just get to the website they have free
shipping nationwide except alaska and
hawaii right now you can get two pounds
of salmon
absolutely free with your first box just
go to butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com
not everyone has convenient access to
high quality meat
well that was a sad way to end it
including that guy in his christmas
sweater
um him
you know you've heard us talking about
hymns now for a while
and how they're helping guys look their
best if you haven't yet
it's time to see what they're all about
problems 66 percent of men start to lose
their hair by age 35
oh i lived it everybody once you've
noticed thinning hair it can be too late
hymns is helping guys to be the best
version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and fda approved
products
to help treat hair loss no snake oil
pills or gas station counter supplements
prescription solutions backed by science
hymns was created by a guy who knows
some men's health
conversations are easier online than in
person
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long pharmacy lines for hims
connects you to licensed medical
professionals online
which could save you hours completely
confidential and discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review
and if they determine it's right for you
uh they can
prescribe you medication to treat hair
loss that is shipped directly to your
door
today hymns is giving you their best
offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund and right now my listeners can
get their first
visit absolutely free go to for hims.com
bird b-u-r-r-e-d
that's for hims.com bird prescription
products require an online consultation
with a health care provider who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply see websites for full
details and important safety information
remember that's for hims.com bird
you know what's [ __ ] nuts about
balding and all of that [ __ ]
is they basically have a cure for it
they just won't give it to you they got
to give it to you in [ __ ] weekly
doses so they got you on the hook for
the rest of your [ __ ] life
it's like just give me the one stop
[ __ ] pill
that's what i'm waiting for oh look who
it is be
undies growing back your [ __ ] hair do
do
do do me undies me undies your wife
dumps you but you don't care
cause you got a lion's mane up on your
head
and you trimmed your balls
uh out in the shadow i [ __ ] it up but
they got soft underwear
put it on your flat top pubes
all right me undies it's almost the new
year which means we all get to hit that
beautiful refresh button
uh there's not an actual button though
unless we're talking about refreshing
your underwear drawer
i thought they're gonna make a [ __ ] joke
there uh then yes there's a button for
that
hey that worked out after the year we
just had me undies wants to give you
some much deserved time for yourself
from the softest undies and loungewear
get them delivered right to your door by
with a click of the button click other
button when was the last time you
refreshed your underwear drawer
could you step up your comfy game for
different prince color styles must read
all right
if you write it i'm going to read it i'm
like bill clinton hey you write it i'll
read it
look at the ass on her all right not
that it's
dark out uh by like
okay now that it's dark out by like 4
p.m all you want to do is become one
with the couch me undies gets it
that's why they want to want to help you
step up your cozy game
their loungewear and undies are super
soft and come in everything from classic
to adventurous prints they literally may
they're they're literally made for your
couch and guess
who what you don't even have to leave
that couch
again with me with the undies membership
can you tell i'm thinking about
something else right now this just
reminded me of something
a subscription that sends new pairs
right to your door
with site-wide savings and exclusive
sales you'll automatically pay
less for everything me undies has a
great offer for my listeners
for any first time listeners uh
purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping uh me undies also
has their problem free
cause i'm a problem child problem free
philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it
no caveats ooh with the big words no
questions i like that word caveat gives
me a little chill down my spine
i really am smart um to get 15
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
that's meundies.com
oh it's the last one here oh look what
it is everybody it's
zendesk you know every day you go to
work or maybe you
zoom in to work and you're sitting
behind a regular desk wouldn't it be
nice to have a zen desk
well what is a zendesk well why don't
you relax all right you pushy [ __ ] i'll
answer the question
all right zendesk everybody customer
service is everywhere
buying stuff online calling your bank
using an app to get a ride
to the airport uh but
even great items sometimes struggle to
make their customers feel taken care of
zendesk's award-winning support sales
and customers customer
engagement software helps businesses
offer personal services at scale let me
read that again
zendesk award-winning support sales and
customer engagement software
helps businesses offer personal service
at scale
so your team can create conversational
experiences that keep customers happy
zendesk gives businesses everything they
need to stay connected with customers
communicate seamlessly across all
channels email
phone chat messenger community forum
help center or social media
zendesk calls that a conversational
experience connected ongoing and natural
customer service interactions
all made possible with zendex complete
customer profile and unified set of
tools
that give you the contacts you need to
deliver great service in every
conversation
most support most support software
requires expensive cons consultants in
months of setup but with zendesk it
takes just an hour to get up and running
just hours to get up and running on top
of being quick to implement
zendesk software easily scales to meet
changing needs zendesk gives
organizations the flexibility to move
quickly focus on
innovation and adapt to growth last
paragraph everybody
and with over 150 000 paid customers
accounts
and over a decade of experience they've
gotten pretty good at customer service
themselves
see for yourself why the best customer
experience experiences are built with
zendesk get started at zendesk.com
that's
zen z-e-n all right zulu echo november
desk dot-com slash bur
all right there we go okay all right
we got through the advertising everybody
hey you know what's great nobody's
[ __ ] bitching about that
baby it's cold outside song i actually
heard it in a store the other day
you know remember that when white women
were so bored they were like let's
decide what
christmas music people can listen to
um here's one for all you feminists out
there why don't you guys check out santa
baby
oh my god i was listening to that song
i'm like that this song right here is
why i waited until 45 to get married
santa baby a [ __ ] suck your dick
if you buy me a duplex
if you don't i'll go and [ __ ] your
friends honey
and trim my [ __ ] tree
um sorry uh the hitler mustache
explained
okay here we go santa baby
a [ __ ] diamond ring for me scooby
um
i can't believe madonna covered that
song
[Laughter]
oh god that's one of the i don't want to
get into it
just i mean jesus christ how about going
against type
and just saying have yourself a merry
little christmas
it's like do you just kind of [ __ ] up
everything it's just it's just the same
thing every time
that'd be like if i came on this podcast
and all i did was scream [ __ ] every week
oh wait a minute
all right the hitler mustache explained
hitler's mustache was very fashionable
among world war one
soldiers of which he was one because it
did not interfere with the gas mask i'm
calling [ __ ] on that
a regular-sized mustache would not
interfere with the gas mask
it's the seam that goes around your face
and i'm not a firefighter but i played
one in a movie
and that's why you're allowed to have a
[ __ ] mustache
and i'd like to say i had a nice big
[ __ ] red one
in that movie and there was no problem
with keeping the seal so
i that's [ __ ] uh nice attempt at
explaining it
do you know how small the gas mask would
have to [ __ ] well let me look that up
let's see
world war one gas mask world war
one gas mask
oh wait a minute
that's classic me i'm comparing it to a
dude give me a [ __ ] break my god they
have one for their donkey too
the donkey's whole face is a [ __ ]
mustache and for some reason that
thing's still alive
yeah i'm calling [ __ ] you could have
if you could have a [ __ ] tom selleck
mustache
look at hitler's you look at hitler's
mustache in world war one
he looks like he's in a barbershop
quartet
oh i love it for once i said [ __ ]
and i was right
all right here we go let's read more
about hitler why did hitler's make his
mustache like that
let's see we got did he copy from
charlie chaplin hitler's mustache was a
variation of an early 20s style called
the toothbrush mustache
before the mustache became popular in
germany at the turn of the 20th century
the predominant german mustache style
was the kaiser mustache
that's what hitler had in world war one
it looks like
or kaiser bar kaiser bart named after
the german emperor kaiser wilhelm um
all right so it's just it was a
toothbrush mustache it was in style okay
well i i still don't have the answer but
i'm i'm not believing that
i don't think it would interfere um but
i guess if he had that big
kaiser one but you could have had a more
of a regular one i don't know i still
think that's [ __ ] all right here we
go next one
[ __ ] baby yoda you're the cutest thing
in the mandalorian
you know what i'm glad you didn't make
me say that
[Laughter]
come on dude there's nothing more
adorable than the baby yoda come on
um oh we got some more [ __ ] here or some
more
french stuff here we got some more
french stuff here i'm totally committed
to learning this [ __ ] i'm not stopping
this time
it might take me 10 years to get [ __ ]
fluent but i am not stopping
um because it's it's all of a sudden i'm
i'm finding all these
great movies and all these actors in
these movies and directors
and it's just like yeah this it's really
stupid to just sort of
stay in your own culture at this point
when you have the internet you can kind
of
you know you can become your own
globalist
all right sir demand
uh what does that mean on-demand little
word
in french what is mott i always forget
that word i got the moths
mot french
the word mart comes from the french word
for word okay look at that look at that
i just translated half a sentence
hello bill bhutan i know what i mean say
stefan
j43 i i'm going to translate this hello
bill burr
bill button bhutan i don't know what
bhutan means
um it's stefan i'm 43 years old
i'm writing you from paris uh
anecdote les amounts
something nine it's a good film
french film that
passes on the pontin of
perry i think it's about that when the
australians
are
all right lovers on ninth bridge is what
it's called
but it isn't the something it's
the celebration of pontinuff the new
bridge
oh is that is this about the love bridge
where everybody put the lovelock bridge
and they put all the locks on it
i don't know 1607.
i like a lot i like your podcast a lot
kisses and waterfalls go [ __ ] yourself
all right but look at that man i'm
starting to figure this [ __ ] out
all right i'm gonna give myself a pat on
the back
you know what's funny when i was young
when i was a little kid
uh i told you this before my
parents were friends with this guy
jacques
who was from france he eventually moved
back and we lost touch with them
although i know they wrote them
every christmas for years and
um when i was little
my parents called me billy and when he
heard that to him it sounded like
belly so he used to call me billy button
and then that became that became like a
thing like a nickname
when i was a kid up from this french guy
so it's kind of funny that now i'm going
all the way back to that
um
yeah i swear to god everything is just
you just [ __ ] stick with it for three
weeks and then all of a sudden
you you make an improvement and then you
get psyched about that and then you just
keep going
you know and i feel like most people
don't know that considering
they made it at mo like 30 of people
after three days of wearing masks
had an absolute like temper tantrum
like the amount of people out there
acting like [ __ ] toddlers i killed it
when you
wear it yeah all right operation
cinder triggered my ptsd
what hey billy storm trooper reject burr
i just saw episode 15 of the mandalorian
and i gotta say for a few seconds you
had me believing you served with me
it's called acton brother it's called
being completely full of [ __ ]
um served with me in afghanistan uh so
kudos on your acting
well i've always been a great
bullshitter so you're i i appreciate
that thank you
i really enjoyed your character may fell
and i could relate to the pain
anger and sleeplessness of the combat
veteran
i was a sergeant in operation enduring
freedom
from 2008 to 2009 with the 349th combat
support hospital
attached to the 101st airborne division
jesus how do you i even remember that
it's long enough forget about knowing
what to do in combat um i was in a
medical unit so although i wasn't in the
field putting holes
into the enemy i was bagging and tagging
soldiers
marines old people and children oh god
as you can imagine it left a lasting
impression on me
like mayfeld i looked back and wondered
what the [ __ ] was it all for
it's infuriating to know that so many
lives were lost and for what minerals
precious gems and natural gas i felt
mayfeld's boiling rage as the offer
officer imperial officer valen hess
um explained how the elude brown eyes
i loved how he said that explained how
the illusion of
fighting for freedom was a gateway into
instilling order
that all those dead stormtroopers were
necessary
that whole scene brought up old memories
of war and i realized that it was an
emulation of afghanistan he did a great
job bill
and pay great homage to us vets who live
with the anger in sleepless nights
um i'm glad i didn't know all of this
before i did that scene i would have
[ __ ] it up
lastly go check out my book one angry
veteran on amazon
ah but he brings it around to hype his
book you gotta love that that's the
hustle
i love it i can never get mad at a
hustle you'll get a better idea of why
some of us vets are the way we are
i'd love to get your feedback on it all
right i'll check that out any wage
this is the second email i wrote your
ass so be sure to read it on the podcast
let me know
when you do and go [ __ ] yourself all
right well i hope you listen to that
um yeah i gotta i'm not gonna lie to you
i got a couple
uh i got a couple
um i got a couple of emails from people
that
served saying how they really liked that
scene and by the way the name of the
actor
who played um valen hesse's richard
colin break
uh brown eyes
i loved how he said that we had so much
goddamn fun
doing that scene um
and just in general justin uh
just in general on that whole episode we
just had a great time
and people are giving me a lot of credit
for coming up with lines and throw i
threw in
a few things but whatever the [ __ ]
that tps thing was um
i thought that that was a star wars
reference i didn't know that that was
a office space and i've seen office
space and i've seen star wars so
you know they have an incredible writing
staff over there they don't need me to
throw things in i think john and
everybody over there knows what they're
doing
which by the way i was so psyched i saw
john favreau was trending
on uh on twitter after the the
final episode and you know
he made a lot of people really happy
with what he did
with the the whole star wars universe i
guess they call it so
um that's pretty cool very happy for him
all right a story from yemen
hey billy mars balls i don't know what
that means
oh it's the red planet i get it [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um all right guys is such dicks
my name is mo
what is it's pronounced the dutch number
eight without
the t at the end i don't know what that
is sham
i'm 20 i'm a 23 year old fat [ __ ] oh
well come on over here man you'd
probably be considered in shape
184 centimeters 127 ish
kilograms because i i don't even want
any of that means because i used to use
imaginary numbers
because i don't use imaginary numbers
are we saying what he actually is
all right let's let's we got to look
this up now for the americans here
184 cm in
feet
all right he's six feet tall all right
so you got that going for you
you're a tall drink of water there nice
all right um
127 ish
kilograms that was right is that it i
hope that's the right metric thing i
don't know anything about metrics
other than water boils at 100
celsius and freezes at zero which right
there you know that that's the better
thing to use where we're like 212
and 32 degrees it could be so much
easier if we run metric but we don't
um into pounds but in the english use
stones
all right so he's six feet tall 279
pounds all right you're a little beefy
i don't know how big bones you are um
how big your head is it's usually it
says what kind of weight you can have i
think
um all right i don't use imaginary nouns
and from yemen
as you may have heard there is a civil
war due to poor education
small-minded [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ]
going on but it's also only in certain
areas don't get me wrong my country is
[ __ ] beautiful we have the oldest
skyscrapers in my hometown
we live life normally in the cities
i'm an i.t student in my oh this is one
of these uh from the
middle east it literally said a story
from yemen and i
was so thinking about
shooting that scene in star wars all
right sorry about that i'm an i.t
student in my third year trying working
oh i know it [ __ ] me up because he
said like the the
oh the deutsche number the german number
so you had me thinking europe here
it doesn't take much to throw me off
people all right my third and final
attempt at reading this paragraph
i'm an i.t student in my third year
trying
uh working my way through life i smoke
weed every day because snoop said that i
should
i listen only to english music because i
hate arabic music
i have a very big interest in the cosmos
and listen to
star talk radio dr neil degrasse tyson's
podcast
i only use the what's up what the
whatsapp
because i'm not a social media junkie i
speak perfect english
i know how you use i know how to use
your
and your a lot of us don't and love
listening to your podcasts and many
others i actually met a couple of guys
and became very close friends instantly
they were watching paper tiger
this is crazy you're watching that [ __ ]
all the way over there
we talked about how you dave chappelle
trevor noah
gabriel iglesias andrew schultz and many
others
and we came to the agreement that
chappelle is the goat of comedy i would
not argue that
that goes without saying but you are
number two i am a piece of [ __ ]
and all of our favorite comedians list i
don't know how you feel about
anime oh i watched the uh i was watching
that one show
the [ __ ] i forgot it i started
watching it
the guy [ __ ] punches people he
doesn't want to be a superhero
anime
i am e
um superhero reluctant
alopecia
yeah that's him right there
what's his name
is it a bird is it a plane is it a
[ __ ] youtube video i just need the
[ __ ] answer
what's his name
the 10 best no i want to know who this
[ __ ] guy's name is you [ __ ]
nine how do i get into anime this is not
what i'm asking
anime superhero alopecia and i support
name
name come on give me the answer
the best bald animated kid why won't
they just give me the [ __ ] answer
because you know what they all want you
to click on it
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is the new internet
thing it used to the answer used to
[ __ ] come up
what is the name of this [ __ ] guy
seven
six five and you know what's gonna be
number one four three
and here's the advertising clicked off
that
one punch man one punch man is my [ __ ]
um all right he watches anime
but i don't know how you feel about
japanese anime but i want to recommend
a show for you it's called one punch man
i'm such an idiot
it's i'm such an idiot i just i'm such a
[ __ ] idiot
season one is 12 episodes only and very
entertaining yeah i loved it
i love you and i love your work and hope
to see you live i wish you can come here
but i don't recommend it at all with
that being said i hope you have a
fantastic year in 2021 i feel i hope the
same for you
because i was raised right i'm gonna end
by saying go fornicate yourself
nice he's not gonna curse p.s i hope
you're okay with us
torrenting your stuff because my country
is a third world country and we don't
have
digital currency we can't pay for it
even if we wanted to i try to make it up
by watching i don't give a [ __ ] dude do
whatever you want
um i don't care i'm just that's amazing
that you guys are watching it and that
you know all of those other
comics too you got great taste in in uh
comedy you know be amazing if one of you
guys started a stand-up scene over there
opened a funny bone right then i could
do a weekend
all right advice see was all about me
advice
asian men and broads all right this is
interesting i never heard this this uh
i don't think i've ever had i'm already
anticipating i've not had this question
before bill
as an asian man oh my god i was at a
four-way
stop the other day and i
[ __ ] up and pulled out in front of
this guy and this asian dude's looking
at me
like what the [ __ ] is your problem and i
wanted to be like huh you see
stereotypes aren't true are they
i was the idiot all right as an asian
man i feel like the system
is rigged against me for romance
i'm a senior in college right now pretty
fit awesome grades no [ __ ] somewhat
a gym bro and i've had experiences
before
on one in on first and second base but
can't seem to hit a home run with the
ladies
these broads in college just don't think
asian men are attractive whether it's
the small dick jokes being i mean that
didn't help you guys
being the most non-attractive male race
just ain't gonna cut it even if you have
confidence
in just approach dude cancel all of that
[ __ ]
cancel as a bald redheaded male dude
what you need is a vibe
i'm gonna send you a [ __ ] video man
i'm gonna send you a [ __ ] video i'm
gonna have the great
john travolta is vinnie barbarino
set you [ __ ] straight this is one of
my favorite [ __ ] clips
it's hilarious and it's in in a way it's
absolutely true
go on instagram i'm gonna post it uh
this is he's teaching arnold horschack
he's teaching arnold schwarz uh horshack
about how to be
uh how to how to get with the lid dude
all you need is a vibe
okay you just need a [ __ ] vibe uh
he said i'm i'm about to commission into
the army soon as an officer and i'm
worried it'll be harder to find romance
what are your thoughts
and [ __ ] you uh this is my thoughts
hit the gym [ __ ] get your confidence
up
i'm feeling like you like the comic
who's walking on stage
already feeling like they're gonna bomb
and then they bomb
i feel like you're on your heels all
right
who gives a [ __ ] just be [ __ ] you
know do it
who gives a [ __ ] just get up there and
swing for the fences
you're gonna connect at some point and
you're gonna get laid and then you're
going to get the monkey off your back
you're going to be relaxed and you know
it's going it's going to be raining
all right that's how you got to think
about it all right you're going to do
you're going to do fine all right i mean
if i did all right out there you're
gonna do fine you're gonna do great
okay just [ __ ] i cannot stress that
enough
you gotta just have confidence and you
gotta have a sense of humor dude
hitting on chicks and getting shut down
okay getting the heisman is [ __ ]
hilarious and once you find the whole
the humor in it dude
bombing is a comic this something that's
humiliating is it's [ __ ] funny it's
[ __ ]
making mistakes [ __ ] up is hilarious
all right and if you can laugh at
yourself and not give a [ __ ]
all this people want to be around you
because everybody wants to because
everybody like
that's what people are going for in life
is when something bad happens
to not let it depress them so they can
enjoy life rather than walking around
you know moping around listening to
[ __ ] emo music and just
giving in to the fact
you know that you know things haven't
worked out to you at that point in life
[ __ ] all of that dude [ __ ] all of that
okay i mean jesus christ
you're in the prime of your goddamn life
all right
you're a little bit of a late bloomer i
was too it all works out
okay you hear me it's gonna work out and
i'm posting that vinnie barbarino
clip just for you all right all right
dumb questions for employees
dairy manager so my point is is go out
there and start hitting on [ __ ]
chicks
and stop talking thinking about
yesterday's game go out and you win
um tonight question for employees dairy
manager
hey oh billy wonka at the cheese
at the ginger factory
ah [ __ ] i i like that one huge
fan love the stand up podcast efforts
for family all of it
i got some remarkably stupid questions
for you
i was the dairy manager milk eggs yogurt
orange juice etc i don't think orange
juice is
dairy i don't think that's dairy sir but
you know what i'm a dumb [ __ ]
orange juice is
it dairy oh my god it came up
in almost every grocery store orange
juice is in the dairy section
oh that's what he's saying calling it
the dairy it's just shorthanded because
the largest group of things there
is milk butter cheese yogurt are all
dairy that's why it's
okay that's why it's usually sold under
dairy okay i'm sorry
i get it at a grocery store for years
and the amount of
just asinine questions i would get still
makes me question
humanity to this day oh so you saw this
year coming all right
here we go top five dumb ass questions
people ask
an employee at a grocery store in the
dairy section which includes
orange juice uh number one
aren't you cold back here aren't you
cold back there
i'm in a giant [ __ ] refrigerator
wearing a heavy jacket
and a beanie even in the middle of
summer you could say it's a bit
nippy number two
can my daughter pet the cows one of my
favorites this woman thought that we had
a pasture
out behind the store the store was in
the middle of the city by the wa
by the way and she thought that we
milked and bottled it all right there
i'm not a farmer ma'am i thought my name
tag and retail job gave that away
um all right number three i'm not losing
any weight even though i eat this yogurt
every day why is that
first of all i don't know and i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm not your personal trainer second if
the guy bothered to read the ingredients
he would have seen how much sugar is in
yogurt i'm not saying it's not healthy
healthier than a donut but there could
be up to 25 grams of sugar in one little
cup
wow i why would you i don't like sugar
and yogurt
i like that greek yogurt it's got that
little that that
tang to it uh number four
do you grow the oranges here on site
well a lot of people feel like when they
go to the grocery store there's a farm
out back huh
do you see an orange grove in the
parking lot no then sorry pal you just
have to assume that your minute made
extra calcium low pulp
mange infused orange juice was probably
bottled in a factory somewhere
number five how do you make blah blah
blah
i'm not sure ma'am if the recipe calls
for a heavy whipping cream i can grab
one for you
but that's the extent of my knowledge
maybe go ask the bakery
or better yet that smartphone in your
hand
bonus uh you won't tell anyone will you
this one was by far the worst let me
start by pointing out
that i had a small desk in the warehouse
liquor store room there was no camera in
the room so often times i would come
back and find one of the baggers trying
to sneak in
an extra break texting things like that
it never bugged me though
i did the same thing at their age but
one night i was working late and came
back
to find one of our floor managers who
was 32
33 at the time and covered in disney
themed tattoos
making out with a topless 16 year old
bagger girl on top of my [ __ ] desk
whoa this dude went in
now for everybody freaking out here this
might be one of those states where 16 is
legal
i don't i'm not looking that up i draw
the line at orange juice being dairy
uh he immediately let go of her and
started apologizing to me
begging me not to say anything i like to
think that
i'm a cool guy but i'm not cool then i'm
going to let this dude make out with a
half naked teenager on my desk
she was a sweet girl from a troubled
family so this creep knew exactly what
he was doing oh okay
okay needless to say i came back the
next day and told my boss but he told me
that the floor manager in question
put his two weeks in that morning
and then you just let it go
yeah i'd say the milk went bad on that
one all right sorry
bob lazar's science shop
okay wow that was that was a hell of a
story there
bob lazar's science shop hi bill i work
at a scientific
supply store united nuclear
which specializes in pyrotechnic
chemicals high power
magnets radioactive materials and moa
the owner is bob lazar who is known for
his scientific endeavors
as well as his experience at area 51
in reverse engineering the propulsion
engine
of a ufo for the u.s government what
the owner is bob lazar who is known for
his scientific as well as his
experience at area 51 in reverse
engineering the propulsion engine of a
ufo for the u.s government
you may have seen his appearance on joe
rogan as well as his
biographical documentary on netflix as
you may have guessed the nature of bob's
business
and background tends to generate a lot
of interest from some very
eclectic people i've saved some of the
funniest and craziest emails of my seven
years
working for him here are my top five
favorite questions from customers all
right this should be crazy
i placed an order for 47 million and i
did not see
how much uranium i could buy could you
cancel my order
do you actually think that heat comes
from the sun then why doesn't the
iss rotate so that those inside don't
get roasted
i what i thought that was still part of
the first one do you think
do you think that heat comes from the
sun then why doesn't the iss
rotate so that those inside don't get
roasted
what is i don't know what the iss is
iss
what do i type in science sun
what images for iss sun
space station sails across the sun
nasa reveals stunning photos of ice oh
was this just an
unmanned thing
oh is it was the iss like a satellite
that they sent an unmanned satellite out
there
i don't i don't know i don't think i
think i'm too dumb for this i don't want
to buy
pure red mercury for medical okay i want
to buy pure red mercury for medical use
to inject the stem cell for sick people
how much is it per gram
is your product past the dog smell test
from the airport
oh does your product pass i found out
that almost 4 000 members of my family
were killed in the holocaust in germany
i'm contacting you today as i would like
to document
anti-semitism do you sell
an emp gun that can destroy the implant
inside of my heart
are these just all random questions how
could one person have four thousand
members of their family
they did a lot of [ __ ] i'm a wonder
i'm wondering how
you test a body like mine for radiation
or nuclear
waste i'm a stolen possessed soul
and i need to know how to prove it do
you know of any
sensitive listening devices that can
hear screams and cries of souls that are
being stolen and possessed by satan
bonus question dude these are [ __ ]
wild
i placed 40 i placed an order for 47
million
i didn't and i did this to see how much
uranium
i could buy could you cancel my order
that's how i got to read some of these
again
i want to buy pure red mercury for
medical use to inject the stem cell for
sick people
how much is it per gram does your
product pass the dog smell test from the
airport
i found out almost 4 000 members of my
family were killed in the holocaust in
germany
i'm contacting you today as i would like
to doc to document
anti-semitism do you sell an emp
gun that can destroy the implant inside
of my heart
wow all right bonus question
could you remove the polonium
polonium from my order
mother wasn't as enthusiastic as i was
to be able to buy some
even with the lead the lead container
i had bought for the purpose of getting
a piece of radioactive material
i may be 28 but her house her rules
dude people are [ __ ] nuts and thank
you for the opportunity to share these
bizarre questions
um so-and-so and i are big fans of your
look
fans of yours and look forward to
hearing your hilarious rants every week
i'm particularly fond of hearing
you grow as a person and as a father oh
thank you as a single 30 year old
it gives me hope for myself and the
future as always go [ __ ] yourself yeah
do it if i can do it you can do it
all right um okay i think that's it
that's the podcast everybody
um have yourselves a merry christmas
[ __ ] week
go out in your cars drive out and look
at the [ __ ] lights all around
but don't get out and hug a [ __ ]
stranger
until you get the vaccine all right
that's it all right go [ __ ] yourselves
have a wonderful week i'll check in on
you on thursday
you